so imagine that there's an emergency
dragon
there's a dragon
someone comes and says there's a dragon
i'm the guy to deal with it
that's what the environmentalists say
the radical types who push limits to
growth
then i look at them and i think okay
is that dragon real or not
that's one question well i asked that
question of myself every time i spend
time alone is the apocalypse looming on
the environmental front yes or no i'll
just leave that aside for the time being
i think you can make a case both ways
for a bunch of different reasons and
it's not a trivial concern
and we've overfished the oceans terribly
and there are environmental issues that
are looming large
whether climate change is the cardinal
one or not is a whole different question
but we won't get into that that's not
the issue you're clamoring about a
dragon
okay
why should i listen to you
well let's see how you're reacting to
the dragon
first of all you're scared stiff and in
the state of panic
that might indicate you're not the man
for the job
second
you're willing to use compulsion to
harness other people to fight the dragon
for you
so now not only are you terrified
you're a terrified tyrant
so then i would say well then you're not
the moses that we need to lead us out of
this particular exodus
and maybe that's a neurological
explanation it's like if you're so
afraid of what you're facing
that you're terrified into paralysis and
nihilism and that you're willing to use
tyrannical compulsion to get your way
you are not the right leader for the
time
so then i like someone like bjorn
lomberg or matt ridley or marion toopey
and they say well look we've got our
environmental problems
and uh maybe there's a there you could
make a case that there's a malthusian
element in some situations
but fundamentally the track record of
the human race is that we learn very
fast and faster all the time to do more
with less
and we've got this
and i think
yes
to that idea
and i think about it in it
in a fundamental way it's like i trust
lomberg
i trust tupe
trust matt ridley
they thought about these things deeply
they're not just saying oh the
environment doesn't matter whatever the
environment is
you know the environment i don't even
know what that is that's everything the
environment i'm concerned about the
environments like
which is how is that different than
saying i'm worried about everything
how are those statements different
semantically
well yeah the environment it could be
i'm worried about human society a lot of
these complex systems are difficult to
talk about because there's so much
involved for sure yeah everything
and then these models
because people have gone after me
because i don't buy the climate models
well
i think about the climate models as
extended into the economic models
because the climate model is
well there's going to be a certain
degree of heating let's say by 2100 it's
like okay
some of that might be human generated
some of it's a consequence of warming
after the ice age this has happened
before but fair enough let's take your
presumption
although there are multiple presumptions
and any error in your model multiplies
as time extends but to have it your way
okay now we're going to extend the
climate model so to speak into the
economic model so i just did an analysis
of a paper by deloitte
third biggest
company in the u.s
300 000 employees major league
consultants they just produced a report
may i wrote an article for it in the
telegraph which i'm going to release
this week on my youtube channel
said well
if we get the climate problem under
control
economically because that's where the
models are now being generated on the
economic front so now we have to model
the environment that's climate and we
have to model the economy
and then we have to model their joint
interaction and then we have to predict
100 years into the future
and then we have to put a dollar value
on that
and then we have to claim that we can do
that
which we can't
and then this is our conclusion
we're going to go through a difficult
period of privation
because if we don't accept limits to
growth there's going to be a catastrophe
50 years in the future thereabouts and
so to avert that catastrophe
we are going to make people poorer
now
how much poor well not a lot compared to
how much richer they're going to be but
definitely
and they say this in their own models
definitely poorer definitely poorer
than they would be if we just left them
the hell alone
and so then i think okay
poor array
who
well let's look at it biologically
you've got a hierarchy right of
stability and
security
that's a hierarchy or one type
you stress a hierarchy like that a
social hierarchy so there's birds in a
environment and an avian flu comes in
and then you look at the birds in the
social hierarchy and the
the low ranking birds have the worst
nests so they're most exposed to wind
and rain and sun and farthest from
food supplies and most exposed to
predators and so those birds are
stressed which is what happens to you at
the bottom of a hierarchy you're more
stressed because your life is more
uncertain you're more stressed your
immunological function is compromised
because of that
you're sacrificing the future for the
present
an avian flu comes in and the birds die
from the bottom up
that happens in every epidemic
you die
from the bottom up okay
so they say when the aristocracy catches
a cold the working class dies of
pneumonia all right so now we're going
to make people poorer
okay who
well we know who we make poor when we
make people poorer
we make those who are barely hanging on
poorer and what does that mean
it means they die
and so what the deloitte consultants are
basically saying is
well
you know it's kind of unfortunate
but according to our models
a lot of poor people are going to have
to die
so that a lot more poor people don't die
in the future it's like okay hold on a
sec
which of those two things am i supposed
to regard with certainty
the hypothetical poor people that you're
going to hypothetically save 100 years
from now
or the actual poor people that you are
actually going to kill
in the next 10 years
well i'm gonna cast my law with the
actual poor people that you're actually
going to kill
and so and then i think further it's
like well okay the deloitte consultants
have you actually modeled the world or
is this a big advertising shtick
designed to attract your corporate
clients with demonstration that you're
so intelligent that you can actually
model the entire ecosystem of the world
including the economic system and
predicted a hundred years forward and
isn't there a bit of a moral hazard in
making a claim like that
just like just a trifle especially when
so i talked to bjorn lomberg and michael
leon last week i accepted the un
estimates of starvation this coming year
150 million people will suffer food
insecurity
food insecurity
yeah food insecurity that's the bloody
buzzword
famine
well
michael yawn thought
1.2 billion and then that little spiral
because he said what happens in a famine
is that the governments go nuts crazy
the governments destabilize
and then they appropriate the food from
the farmers
then the farmers don't have any money
then they can't grow crops and i think
yeah that's exactly what they do that's
exactly what would happen
and so
john told me 1.2 billion and then bjorn
lomberg said the same thing i didn't
even ask him he just made it as an
offhand comment
so
let me ask you about
the famine of the 30s yeah
do you think so ukraine in the ukraine
oh yeah
fun fun fun similar
a lot of the things you mentioned in the
last few sentences kind of echo
to that part of human history the holy
door
do you use no one knows about
well
now i've just spent four weeks in
ukraine oh yeah there's different parts
of the world that still
even if they don't know
they know yeah right they feel
history is runs in the dutch knew
in some sense they had a famine at the
end of world war ii and part of the
reason the dutch farmers are so
unbelievably efficient and productive
is that the dutch swore at the end of
world war ii that that was not going to
happen again
and then they had to scrape land out of
the ocean
because holland that's quite a country
it shouldn't even exist the fact that
it's the world's number two exporter you
know that's the world's number two
exporter of agriculture products holland
it's like
i don't think it's as big as
massachusetts it's this little tiny
place it shouldn't even exist
and they want to put here's this here's
the plan
let's put 30 percent of the farmers out
of business
well the broader ecosystem of
agriculture production in holland is six
percent of their gdp now these
centralizing politicians think
tell me if i'm stupid about this
take an industry
you knock it back
by fiat by thirty percent
now it runs on like a three percent
profit margin now you're going to kill
30 percent of it
how are you not going to bring the whole
thing down the whole farming ecosystem
down
how are you not going to
impoverish the
transport systems how are you not going
to demolish the grocery stores
you can't take something like that and
pair it back by fiat by 30 percent
and not kill it i i can't see how you
can do that i mean look what we did with
the covid lockdowns we broke the supply
chains
tried buying something lately
you can't and wait and aren't the
chinese
threatening taiwan at the moment what
are we going to do without chips
so
i don't know what these people are
thinking and then i think okay what are
they thinking well the deloitte people
are thinking aren't we smart and
shouldn't we be hired by our corporate
employers it's like okay
too bad about the poor
um what are the uh
environmentalists thinking we love the
planet it's like do you
we love the poor do you okay let's pit
the planet against the poor who wins the
planet okay you don't love the poor that
much do you love the planet
or do you hate capitalism
let's pit those two things against each
other oh well it turns out we actually
hate capitalism how can we tell
because you're willing to break it
and you know what's going to happen so
what's going to happen in sri lanka with
these 20 million people who now have
nothing to eat
are they going to eat all the animals
are they going to burn all the firewood
they're stockpiling firewood in germany
it's like so is your environmental
globalist utopia
going to kill the poor and destroy the
planet and that's okay because we'll
wipe out capitalism it's like okay yeah
the the dragon and the fear of the
dragon drives ideologies some of which
can build a better world some of which
can destroy that world
you